[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est un stagiaire de H2O si tu le
connais pas c'est que bah alors attends
encore faudrait-il venir au bureau
Cyril demain c'est bon
c'est votre anniversaire demain mais
votre fête c'est ce soir puisque vous
savez pourquoi vous me payez peut-être
pas pour me défoncer alors j'aurais pas
du jusque là je reste dans les limites
du raisonnable mais pour regarder tout
ce qui se passe pendant les pubs pendant
les offres pendant les Magnéto et il y a
des choses qu'on devrait pas diffuser
mais qu'on va diffuser quand même c'est
la Gazette des offres mais c'est pas
d'histoire
[Musique]
et on commence avec vous Cyril toujours
très rassurant quand il y a des
mauvaises nouvelles
pas tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
sur la batardise et ça ça n'a pas changé
et d'ailleurs je savais qu'on était
précoce chez Hanouna mais pas à ce
point-là
[Musique]
commence par arrêter tes camions diesel
avant de nous faire chier avec les
jeunes
si vous êtes numéro un des producteurs
on le sait mais aussi numéro un chez les
productrices la preuve avec Alexa la
radio
[Musique]
on continue avec Matthieu Delormeau qui
nous offre comme à son habitude une
belle leçon d'humilité et bienveillance
50 secondes avec du blanc goût et tout
ça
[Applaudissements]
je vous laisse vous expliquer
ai mon père pour un bon mot voilà voilà
tétanos
je pense qu'il y aura un prochain rideau
[Rires]
je sais pas si vous avez vu à la fin du
dernier magnéto mais Nino venait de
croire parce qu'elle bataille non loin
fontaine d'ailleurs donc il faut
toujours les deux sur le fait qu'il est
Ken avec Afida Turner vous l'avez cru
c'est vrai que Nino est très drôle mais
parfois il peut être un peu con
[Rires]
et sans vouloir lui faire offense quand
il tombe dans entre les mains des deux
plus grands magouilleurs du paysage de
visuel français monsieur Cyril Hanouna
et monsieur Guillaume Genton et bien ça
donne une séquence digne d'un film je
vous la fait en une phrase lors d'une
pub série Les Guillaume sont allés voir
Nino et lui ont fait croire que Daniel
Moreau avait été enchanté par Nikos
Aliagas non non j'en ai pas plus
enfanté par Nikos
bon Nikos Nikos
regardez c'est en images
il était une fois sur le plateau de TPMP
un chroniqueur qui a fait croire un
autre chroniqueur un peu con il faut
l'avouer que je vais Ken avec Daniel
Moreau
n'importe quoi ils ont pas le même âge
mais jusqu'ici ce n'était rien
l'animateur le plus ma ligue du PAF a
décidé de s'en mêler Daniel qui est
enceinte de Nico
en Grèce
tu vois là
pour ninhos le piège va beaucoup trop
loin Daniel Laurent pas me regarde pas
Daniel si Nino il parle de Nico c'est un
moment il faut que tu partes en couille
ouais genre tu dis ouais Nico j'aimerais
qu'on parle pas de Nikos je savais très
bien ce qui s'est passé regardez bien la
suite Cyril Hanouna est un immense tabac
il y a plein de gens qui se disaient et
vous avez gagné énormément vous étiez un
petit peu comme Nico à l'époque en fait
il y a des sujets quand même enfin Nico
on avait dit il faut pas y toucher Nico
[Rires]
de Noël
ça te dérange pas oui mais c'est privé
[Rires]
t'inquiète pas je le ferai plus
[Musique]
[Rires]
ils m'ont dit que apparemment tu as
avorté de Nikos
il y a des choses dont on peut pas
parler elle est vraiment vénère
et surtout pas parler de ça et là c'est
pas bien ce que tu fais est-ce que tu as
Ken avec Nikos
[Rires]
ils l'ont bien [ __ ] Nino ne t'en fais
pas Daniel un jour je te ferai te fêter
[Applaudissements]
bles
en plus c'est vrai c'est plausible
autour de cette table bah c'est
Guillaume Genton absolument c'est
Guillaume j'attends la matinale de
Virgin les production tout lui un peu
monté à la tête c'est devenu le plus
grand Charo il veut toutes les Ken sauf
qu'il assume pas
[Musique]
je bouge plus une oreille je drague
aucune meuf même là sur le plateau
c'est pas les oreilles donc je suis
droit comme la justice droit comme la
justice j'ai arrêté tout acte de drague
envers quiconque
personne sur le bateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous rappelez de cette petite
séquence rappelez-vous
[Applaudissements]
Jacques Chirac qui fait un peu de
playback sachez qu'il y a eu la même
séquence sur votre plateau avec celle
qu'on appelle désormais Valérie ben
Chirac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]